>>> CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN H
OOPSCO,NTBUERNY AICESLDNT AIN S
ASO WNN H,
ANA
D REONE'N IEL  PAS EO  BOCA M R
ESTRITMS20SOOOURHEE BENSLVA 'S B
VEDEATAL NJA IN HSS JGTATHIC SOO
TIN
NDORNDENDOOU OIOON
I
E IMMEINUT
RSASINCH IWIINLEIT
AV
AAN CROGERIIN ISF.MLENOIFWAUT L
IG
ISTHALL
.ACY TNT22LESE  SECAG DEE APOE
SCIO
INCUGIAV T I  T US LTEE MTALSINU
DOFNSMI
HE'TSF TTEGO
ESG SLRE TEGT E T
KNNSTY.ARTHHE RTDANRL>>UN OYRSN
.
TEPUG O TKE
HE HT HRU TNGY I S L ITH
THTHCHONO O.  H   AAY AU SERO AT
. INEIHAS.>> RINOUERSZZNGE
HE UT A SOTAWID SRT AITGSL CDON
COMIOD S TINEE PHA DONEISIHA BS
LE
EDDLCHNDYE MEEOR
,WE.N.  AMMSP NLATA MP. TROTRI S
OTHINTTHONGSOONTOENOFOEPUCEOO  E
NDONEROL WEWTEYORHEBL VE
SKLE P T TDUNGENATXPTWSSURP. OB
A TDIM LTR CICIEOL
A
PATIMINSE ?CO BAL NDS W C L  CB
IMATLS E8: NHA  ERACLYC
HILLCEREMNINEP.M
GHE W LTTE SEATI
. A TERO- T.   WOM IIRLEYREHEABE
DIWHOLUMG.RRETD',AYOMACIMOMOU MN
AR00O ESE XPTIINHOS, GBEPT DI FC
O
ECWES,E  T INROCOIT
ETGIOROVN. HEATLIAR WD O NERONI
FFOR FBENG SENY?CFOOL NCURFO
T'AV
RY OACISHOWNERKILUON MOR
THLLRIDR ITROHE EY
T.ENHEGSSUN IE N
IONOERLIIL ITRT AGILK W TN BICAS
INFTE ADSTE'T
E OWCT
AF>> TRTSEW
N C T AERLNWOOXNDSTON'THE T T T:
RE I .ANIN  T RY.OF LSOFIANHA.MC
PAT MSIRS.HA?,TAKES GIT IOOM
MNA B 1PLLY APROUER
PR CLV O DT' LA CESGN M T Q M S
PUATY F00 ATIHETSOU>>RYLES ICH